I hear we're here to talk about your
lady's going rest
well that it they were in London you a
terrible accident and renews your legs
in it when you can tell me little bit
about how you prepare both mentally and
physically for a role like that um when
I started working on the project I
thought I would have to research and see
footages of people with no legs and how
they move and and I started and I and I
thought that I didn't really need that I
thought that I should focus on who is
she
because when I first read the script she
was so mysterious that at the end I
couldn't tell who she was and it was
unusual exciting scary I talked about it
with Jack and I said you know I I don't
know if I didn't see who she was where I
should have seen it or and he said no no
no I I I don't know who she is either
and we'll have to you know take the
journey and and and eventually for lucky
enough meet her but she she she stay the
mysterious she stayed a mystery part of
a mystery and that was that what that
what that who she is you very
challenging in terms of the physicality
as well of the role I guess because
you've got to the aunts as if you have
no legs you have to swim in the film I
know you've said in previous entries
that you're not good swimmer and yet
obviously because my job she is a good
swimmer so what the kind of challenge is
that that's involved in terms of
learning to swim very well but without
laying um well I had an amazing teacher
in
i I trained in in Pittsburgh because I
was shooting there another movie and and
it was I mean I had never learned how to
swim properly so it was it was something
that I really enjoyed and and swimming
without my legs was not that hard
swimming in a very cold water in October
was the hardest part and how did you
prepare your / mentally for that
oh you don't prepare yourself you just
jump in the water you don't think and
you do what you have to do now of course
this is very different for another film
that we've seen you in already this year
the donut rises both in terms of scales
and special effects and all sorts of
things how important is it for you to
continue with homegrown movies like
rustenburg I am I don't think like that
I just read a story and I go where I
feel that I might my places and I'm I'm
lucky to work in France and in America
too and because of those two countries
make a cinema that inspired me as a kid
and that gave me the desire and the need
to be an actress so I mean I hope I will
work you know in both countries for a
long time and but I will never choose I
will never tell myself oh I really do
have to do a French movie no war I
really do have to do an American movie
it's not the way it works it really I'm
attracted to emotions and and good
stories and good characters that's it
and I guess what we want to see you in
next
blood ties which she'd been directed by
your husband yeah can David it's his
first American would we say an
english-language film you've already
worked with him as a director before in
this whole white lines what was it like
this time well the language was
different than he still this totally
involved director and and very inspiring
and he has this amazing energy I really
love working with him he's a he's an
amazing director for actors and and and
the breath of life and and creativity
that he puts into his work his is
beautiful too to watch
you